The desk is the main hub of any workspace,...
...so the key thing to do before organizing your desk...
...is to figure out what the main purpose is of that micro workspace...
...that you're gonna be sitting at for most of your day.
What are the main activities you're gonna be doing,...
...and what are you gonna need close at hand?
The next thing to do is start with a clean slate.
Clear off your desktop, clear out any drawers, anything around the desk.
Start with a clean slate and build up from there.
The next thing to do is keep frequently used items close at hand.
Whether that's an inbox, an outbox, action files, a stapler, a pen,...
...whatever you're gonna need on a day-to-day basis.
Next, file anything unnecessary out of sight.
If you don't need them on a daily or a regular basis,...
...you don't need it within arm's reach.
Keep that space free and clear so you can get in and out easily...
...and do your job without any extra stress or headaches.
Lastly, preserve your desk as a work-only space.
It's really important that the things on and around your desk...
...are all there to help you get your job done and be efficient and effective.
If you keep these tips in mind,...
...you'll be able to keep your desk and your workspace as a whole, more organized,...
...and you'll be able to have a much more productive work experience.